welcome back to new rockstars the batman
is finally giving us a riddler who
actually uses ciphers the way
real-life serial killers do unlike every
other widdler who looks like he's
conspiring with like the hamburglar to
murder
mayor mccheese this is the big question
the podcast that gives you too
much information about how everything
cool about the batman has been lifted
directly from
actual terrifying mass murderers of the
real world
you may have cheered when you heard i'm
vengeance but uh
us true crimers were like uh matt reeves
you fool they never caught zodiac
i'm eric boss here with me to do some
cyphering is our very own hurdy gertie
man
off-screen producer zach huddleston
hello
eric i'm i'm wearing a hat for this
episode because my hair is a little bit
more ted kaczynski than i'd like to
admit okay
hey we could all take a note from ted
kaczynski live out in isolation up in
the woods in montana because
right now our batman are getting too
exposed
to human to human uh transmitted
diseases okay that but that's the only
note we're taking from ted kaczynski
right yes
everything else oh if we also want to
take a professor's job at berkeley
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just everything else that we should
probably avoid
well uh what is our big question this
week well eric
everybody wants to know what real life
serial killers is the batman movie
basing this version of the riddler on uh
okay so i think when we all saw this
trailer we're all like this looks like
zodiac
and maybe it's just those of us who like
care about
real life serial killers what
bro what are you talking about man zach
i don't know about you but
in between the dark night the dark
knight rises i remember there was like a
brief fan
push for the third movie to bring back
the riddler and follow in the footsteps
of heath ledger's joker
and make the riddler like a super dark
one inspired by the unabomber
of course nolan wouldn't do no different
direction
but now it looks like matt reeves is
doing exactly what we wanted
yeah the the dark gritty uh jim carrey
inspired reboot we've
we've been calling for since batman
forever you betcha
yeah that's what that's what we wanted
that's what we wanted i guess the real
question is
do we really want this kind of riddler
because we're going to break down
everything we know about paul dano's
version of this character and how each
component of his character is actually
lifted directly
from some terrifying detail from the
deadliest and creepiest serial killers
in modern american history zach and i
are gonna do
new rockstars version of uh last podcast
on the left or my favorite murder or one
of those great
terrifying stomach turning podcasts last
riddle on the left
can we claim that territory my favorite
multiverse
uh yeah we've already ruined both of
those everyone who's like a subscriber
one of those is like past
all right well let's let's start with
the biggest influence on this riddler
definitely appears to be the zodiac
killer zach and i both live in
california and have for the past decade
and if you're a californian you are
well aware of zodiac he should be on our
state flag maybe he is maybe that bear
on the california state flag was zodiac
because they never caught him right so
who was uh zodiac
zodiac was and maybe is a serial killer
in california accredited for
at least five people murdered from the
period of the late 60s to the early
70s but maybe more zodiac mailed these
cryptic letters to newspapers and police
it's all signed with the code name of
zodiac or z sometimes just with the
symbol that you've seen it is the
target looking thing that showed up
creepily in the background of that
morbius trailer remember that yeah now
one of the later letters that was sent
to media claimed to have taken 37
lives as the years went on zodiac
letters kept saying like
zodiac 37 sfpd zero
but those letters unlike the early ones
were not
directly proven to be zodiac ones some
people believe they may have been
copycats or just other people screwing
with the cops
now zodiac's story was dramatized in the
amazing
david fincher film zodiac starring well
the avengers
basically iron man hulk mysterio or all
in that movie not to mention uh anthony
edwards
dr uh whatever from er yeah
goose yeah they got everyone in this
either dermot mulroney or
dylan mcdermott isn't it one of the two
two you wrote
durable mcdonald's have we ever seen
both those guys in the same room
i don't know that they're not the same
person yeah um there's just so
many cinematic parallels between um this
batman trailer
and zodiac that if you were to watch
zodiac right now you'd be like oh yeah
matt reeves must have watched this movie
to to inspire what he's doing in the
batman just to give you a brief summary
of uh the zodiac's timeline
the movie zodiac opens with the vallejo
attacks uh
attack of mike mageau in the murder of
darlene ferran that took place on july
4th 1969
zodiac like other crimes he called that
one in
and he also claimed in that call to
murder david faraday and betty lou
jensen in december of 1968 and
later on in the investigation he was
also linked to the murder of sherry joe
bates in riverside california based off
of some
uh handwriting samples that were linked
but that wasn't necessarily confirmed
but really the famous zodiac panic began
when
a weeks after the vallejo attack zodiac
mailed letters to three newspapers in
the bay area the san francisco chronicle
san francisco examiner and the vallejo
times herald and he demanded
to all those editors that they print
three parts of a cipher
that he said would reveal his identity
and this was called the z
408 cipher it was shortly thereafter
solved by a teacher
in north salinas donald hardin and his
wife betty and it translated
to the following and i'm not gonna try
to um you know
make zodiac sound too sexy here because
that would be inappropriate also he
might take offense to it because i
assume ted cruz is watching this
or ted cruz's dad we don't know his dad
uh
maybe both um this is what it translated
to i like killing people because it is
so much fun it is more fun than killing
wild game in the forest because man is
the most dangerous animal of all
to kill something gives me the most
thrilling experience is even better than
getting your rocks off with a girl
the best part of it is that when i die i
will be reborn in paradise and all the
people i have killed will become my
slaves i will not give you my name
because
you will try to slow down or stop my
collecting of slaves from my afterlife
charmer i also love he's like i won't i
won't give you my name
but i will give you this elaborate
riddle that kind of hints at my
background
right like that's going to be a
recurring theme that we're going to
explore with these killers like guys
that like
want to taunt while not totally wanting
to be caught
and everything in there you could
interpret as a clue it's part of the
reason zodiac despite not being
you know the highest body count mass
murderer in u.s history
is one of the most famous just because
of all these loose ends and these clues
like you'll see this in the zodiac movie
the whole idea of man is the most
dangerous animal of all was interpreted
as a reference to the short story in
film
the most dangerous game which is about a
man hunter that's when the panic began
his manipulation of the media and then
uh shortly after that in september 1969
zodiac struck again he stabbed
picnickers brian hartnell
and cecilia shepard at lake berry nessa
and napa hartnell survived just like
mike majo survived and then a few weeks
later in october
right down the street from where my
girlfriend used to live
he shot and killed cab driver paul stein
and he teared off pieces of paul stein's
shirt
and he would later mail scraps of this
to a newspaper
and stein was zodiac's last confirmed
murder but there were several others
that he took credit for that some
believe he just read other unrelated
incidents in the newspaper
and took credit for the killing but
other people think that he may have been
involved with others but this is the
last confirmed one and then just moving
right along in november 1969 he mailed a
scrap
of the shirt into the chronicle and had
a new cipher that has been called the
z340 cipher and during this time zodiac
also chatted with attorney
melvin bellai live on a tv call-in show
but that was later
suspected to be a hoax call by a
different mental patient
but it was super cr creepy a lot of
people heard that and watched that live
and were like oh my god this voice
is one of the creepier parts of the
movie this is the zodiac speaking
and then uh the panic spread when uh
zodiac or
someone claiming to be zodiac threatened
to kill kids on school buses and bomb
places
everyone freaked out people were afraid
to send their kids to school it later
resulted in the film dirty hairy in
which the cops were like what if we
didn't care about civil liberties and
just shot
first and then clint eastwood had a
career thereafter yeah
well do you punk
just carry a gigantic gun and all the
bad guys will be too scared to commit
crimes
yes yep yep yep and then years after the
letters continued with all kinds of
threats and
and other ciphers but the last confirmed
cipher that went unsolved for a while
was this
z340 many claimed to have decoded it in
2012
hobbyist corey starliper derived the
following using a cipher of his own that
was based on area codes that people
thought were linked to it but it's
pretty compelling
and i'll just read kind of what it is
here kill self doctor help me
kill myself gas chamber a i o u r
days questions able every waking moment
i'm alive my pride lost i can't go on
living this way killing people i have
killed so many people
can't help myself i'm so angry i could
do my thing i'm alone in this world my
whole life full of lies
i'm unable to stop by the time you solve
this i will have killed 11 people
please help me stop killing people
please my name is
lee allen okay so arthur lee allen is
the primary suspect hinted by the zodiac
film to be the true identity of zodiac
he's played by the
wonderful john carroll lynch lots of
circumstantial evidence lined up with
with alan he had told a friend that he
wanted to kill people under the name
zodiac his travel schedule matched he
did wear a zodiac brand watch he matched
the physical description
he had bloody knives in his trunk he had
the same kind of guns and same kind of
black gloves as the ones that were
described
and he was a convicted child molester
who did time in prison
around the time zodiac kind of stopped
doing stuff
but circumstantial evidence does not
hold up in court you need something that
directly links someone to the crime and
when they try to do this with arthur lee
allen it didn't really work uh they did
handwriting analysis that was
inconclusive
there was dna reports that was also
inclusive
so it has led many to believe that he
wasn't the guy
but depending on who you talk to which
experts you talk to some people say
handwriting analysis is not a good way
that it's not really a real science
and some people say that if they were
able to do further dna testing they
would prove arthur lee allen to be the
guy
i don't know what do you think zack i i
don't know certainly the film zodiac
presents
a pretty strong case that it's arthur
lee allen but that's
a film and part of the reason this case
has fascinated
people for so long is it is so opaque
and there's so many options and like
weird dangling threads
i think you know this case reminds me a
lot both because it's set
in like similar parts of california of
the golden state
killer has recently depicted in the hbo
mini series i'll be gone in the dark
that took decades and decades to solve
that case and only kind of through like
online family tree dna registry where
they eventually able to kind of
get that guy it also makes me think i
mean sadly
the zodiac's probably dead by this point
just of old age
yeah right right right right if somebody
didn't like have like a deathbed
confession we might
never get one i don't know but our
question is how does this zodiac inspire
the riddler that we see
well uh there are definitely
similarities in october 1970 chronicle
reporter paul avery played by
iron man tony stark robert downing jr in
the film he received a halloween card at
the chronicle office
the cover of which had a skeleton with
the creepy
phrase peek-a-boo you are doomed and
inside was a scrap of of
paul stein's shirt his bloody shirt and
and
of course in the batman trailer the
riddler's greeting card has almost the
exact same type of halloween skeleton
with similar message in a and has a
cipher attached to it
and we don't know what else might be in
that envelope that we didn't see in the
trailer that's right
there could be like a weird uh you know
fingernail
that's been torn off a dead body or
something creepy absolutely and then of
course the ciphers are the big thing
the fact that the riddler in this movie
uses these weird symbols and that they
translate to something
is very zodiac-esque and in fact the
glyphs in the trailer translate to heli
still
which you know amateur cryptographers
were able to quickly solve
and it's it's not if you couldn't get
this it doesn't mean you're dumb you
just don't have
a lot of experience doing this stuff
people who have done kind of
cryptography before had like
cryptography merit badge
voice this is a real simple one that we
could crack in like a half hour
um and it's really because it ends in
that double l that is classic
stuff that you look for and it's exactly
what they did to decipher
that that zodiac that first cipher jake
gyllenhaal plays the cartoonist robert
graysmith and he talked about how those
teachers were able to solve that one
what's the most common double consonant
in the english language the double
l and what's the one word that we know
that he'll use in here
double l is exactly how we got the word
still and he lies still
if assuming that is what it translates
to and matt reeves did that like
that must have been pulled directly from
the zodiac mystery
there's also the detail of like in the
trailer here dano's creepy booming voice
if you
are justice please do not lie
like clearly he does want to be heard
which does echo the call
in show where the caller let out
randomly this terrifying scream
which which kind of even if that caller
wasn't zodiac it does
you know remind you of that moment and
then finally zach there is a zodiac's
appearance so the most famous image of
zodiac
was the sketching done from brian
hartnell's description after the lake
stabbing
it's the black hood over the head the
symbol on the chest and then pinched
glasses that he wore
over the hood's eye holes which is just
like what paul dano's riddler does
he wears glasses over the eye holes in
his military cold
weather mask it had such like a great
creepy
storm troopery executioner
vibe to it i mean they they've nailed
from what we've seen so far in the
trailer
they nailed the creepy ethos of like a
scary riddler right any of this mean
anything
to you now the big difference between
this riddler and zodiac i would say are
the targets so zodiac killed seemingly
at random
uh we aren't really sure who all of his
victims were
but riddler is clearly targeting
political figures
the mayor is the the body at the
beginning it looks like he's killing the
d.a
as well he has some kind of political
agenda no more lies
government conspiracy that he's trying
to expose which brings us
to the other really famous serial killer
who we think is influencing here
unabomber so the unabomber who also
has some california legs to his trail uh
something about california in 1969
between these two dudes and uh golden
state killer
and the manson family it was a scary
time to be alive
i think i think it was more like the 80s
but wasn't the night stalker
uh richard ramirez oh yeah
l.a uh grim sleeper again i think that's
later in california but
we've um we're fertile territory here in
the golden state for
for creepy something in the water
something in the non-existent water
so unabomber unabomber was ted kaczynski
theodore john kozinski
uh from 1973 to 1993 he killed
three people but he tried to kill way
more he injured 23 others by mailing 16
bombs to places all over the united
states and the fbi
used the case id unibomb which stood for
university and airline bomber those were
most of his targets
so a bit of background on kaczynski he
was a very very intelligent
mathematics professor at berkeley there
was that joke in good will hunting
where he talked about a guy and he was
worried that matt damon is going to
become the next unabomber then he went
on to berkeley was assistant professor
showed amazing potential then he moved
to montana and he blew the competition
away
but he was teaching at berkeley and then
was liked by his students suddenly out
of nowhere resigned in 1969
[Music]
and then he moved back with his parents
in chicago and then after a couple years
later moved to this remote cabin that he
built
in uh rural montana and while he was
there he got really pissed off at nearby
landscaping and logging and there he
began his life
of domestic terrorism he tried to
sabotage the companies
and realized that wasn't enough so he
started building bombs
that's it nice and hot yeah boy
1978 he tried to bomb northwestern
professor buckley crist
who called in the suspicious package and
then poor campus police officer
terry marker opened it luckily did not
kill him but it did injure his hand
and in 1979 he tried to bomb american
airline flight 444
but a faulty timing mechanism caused it
to smoke so it did not explode
thank god it would have brought down the
plane though that's when the fbi got
involved because
when you try to bomb an airplane that is
a federal crime
so really what's what a lot of people
find interesting about this within each
bomb kozinski tried to throw off
authorities with all these fake
clues like he would uh include these
metal plates that was stamped with the
letters
fc that maybe he was trying to make him
think like oh that was
the name of the the bomber there was a
note left and one bomb that didn't
detonate
and the note said whoo it works i told
you it would
rv which is just nonsense he would use
on all of his mailed bombs uh these one
dollar eugene o'neill stamps
that people were thinking oh this would
be a pattern one bomb was embedded in a
copy of the novel ice brothers
but the fbi did deduce that there was a
theme of nature
in all these because he was like a
nature man and there were bits of tree
branches and bark
and most of his bombs he did bomb grad
student john hauser at berkeley and then
he killed his first victim a computer
store owner
hugh scruton in sacramento and over the
years he injured several others with his
bombs
just because these people didn't die
doesn't mean you know their bodies were
horribly injured and their lives were
affected permanently like
he didn't have that high of a body count
but like he did
ruin a lot of lives and then he killed
at exec thomas j
moser in new jersey apparently because
that ad firm had helped exxon clean up
its image after exxon valdez
and then he murdered timber lobbyist
gilbert brent murray so in 1995
kaczynski wrote to the press that he
would stop committing his acts of terror
if
they published his famous unabomber
manifesto which is a 35 000 word
essay it was titled industrial society
and its future
is really just kind of this rant that uh
technology was destroying society
a theme that may not be wrong but it was
wrong to bomb people to get attention
to the subject if only the internet was
as widely
used back then he could have gotten it
out on social media or just started a
youtube channel for this stuff
yeah and his uh his 97 subscribers would
appreciate his daily
uh three-hour videos yeah
uh and actually when he mailed his
manifesto
janet reno the fbi the justice
department encouraged
the washington post to publish it
because this is how they caught him
uh kaczynski's brother recognized his
writings and it's like oh
damn it that's my crazy brother and yeah
he tipped off the fbi and they arrested
him and they caught him
so how does unabomber inspire the
riddler well obviously the use of bombs
the riddler does strap a neck bomb to
gill
coulson peter sarsgaard the district
attorney but uh we should point out that
the use of a neck bomb in particular
unabomber mailed his bombs and would
trick people into opening the package
the neck bomb seems a bit similar to a
separate incident the killing of brian
wells in eerie pennsylvania in 2003 that
was a scheme
orchestrated it seemed like by marjorie
dale armstrong
and kenneth barnes it was depicted in
that netflix documentary series evil
genius did he see that
oh so good other similarities both
riddler and unibomber are driven it
seems like by political agendas
and both use ciphers kozinski did keep a
coded journal
that he didn't send out to people it's
just his own journal that he ciphered in
case he was ever caught
with and he had a numerical cipher
because he's like a mathematics genius
um
but unfortunately also kept the
encryption key with the journals so they
were able to
decode it and and see it at that point
they already had plenty of evidence but
the fact that he uh
he ciphered them like that is
riddler-esque there's also the dano
riddler appearance
so he wears his military surplus coat a
military cold weather mask it is the
kind of survivalist gear that you might
see the unibomber wearing
he was more famously depicted in the the
police sketch of the hoodie but like
they there is some kind of like
similarity in where they shop i would
say now there are some other influences
from history you could argue
characters like uh jack the ripper maybe
hh holmes
who do inspire many fictional serial
killers uh that you've seen over the
years jack the ripper actually was
a batman villain so in the way that jack
the ripper forced batman to solve the
clue to exonerate himself might be
something that
uh the riddler appears to be doing by
implicating batman and whatever the
conspiracy is
that he's trying to expose but one big
thing about this riddler zack is his use
of duct tape that seems to be
very important to his character and in a
recent episode of rogue theory our
friend uh shukri abdi went to a very
interesting theory that maybe
the riddler's parents were suffocated
with duct tape and now that's how he
like gets back at everyone
by suffocating them with duct tape and
strapping them down with duct tape
it is such a specific choice to do the
entire face duct tape right
we've seen maybe in in other movies
where like
plastic bag and then duct tape to seal
right but then you can still see the
face
but like it's so specific to take the
time that's so much
tape to make sure it's airtight and
yeah i mean do you also think though it
also might possibly be a way
to avoid an r rating because like by
making it opaque you can't see a dead
face that might be a little heavier for
sensors ooh
that's interesting yeah i didn't think
about that but yeah yeah that's
definitely possible but the duct tape is
definitely key to it like a lot of
murder if you try to just look up duct
tape
serial killer a lot of people have
murdered using duct tape to bind their
victims
that's what you get at the hardware
store right you buy a shovel
you buy a bunch of plastic sheets and
you buy some duct tape right that
that's how you know you're about to go
kill somebody duct tape can be used
for anything uh but probably murder
there was someone who was
named the duct tape killer it was a
murderer in south dakota named robert
leroy anderson
who murdered two people it's just really
a book that's trying to find a name for
him and called him the duct tape killer
just because
one of the uh women he killed was
suffocated with duct tape
and the other one they never found her
body but they found pieces of her hair
and her clothing next to a strand of
duct tape that was dangling from a tree
he uh could be it i i doubt he's pretty
obscure i don't know if he would be like
the duct tape killer but the reason
i point this out is this is like the new
part of his mo
that is unique to this killer is the
fact that he uses duct tape so uh keep
an eye on that for any future things you
see about this
any future trailers we're gonna pay very
close attention to the duct tape
and why this riddler uses it whether
it's something psychologically
important to him uh or if it's just
practical in some other way
also you cannot discount that sound
right
yeah pulling the the duct tape open
is like one of the creepiest so as soon
as you get like
oh man the fact that the trailer opened
with that like you see the studio
logos were edited to move along with the
sound of the duct tape i think is very
important and not enough people are
talking about so i think that's where
we're going to see a lot about this guy
so uh in summary paul dano as edward
nashton the riddler i would say
is probably at least 50
zodiac if not more he is mostly inspired
by zodiac and i think
the fact that if you were to say which
murderers in american history are most
like
the riddler zodiac and unabomber are the
two that
in terms of the leaving clues the
mailing things
and uh the really messed up political
agendas that are involved that that
seems to be
so it's mostly zodiac mostly unibomber
maybe a bit of a
dash of jack the ripper thrown in there
as well because jack the ripper also
mailed stuff into
london's police and a lot of people
didn't know if all those were from the
same jack the ripper he was also never
caught but he killed mostly sex workers
which this riddler doesn't seem to be
doing he has higher profile targets
so there you have it solved this fun
fictional character used to wear all
green and skip around and
lock people up in these weird goofy
mazes now he's pulled directly from the
scariest headlines in american history
you're welcome who would have thought
the batman would be a crossover with law
order special victims unit
all right before we move on we want to
thank some friends who helped us make
this episode start with our friends at
expressvpn
so when you use your bathroom you always
close the door behind you right right
yes and i hope so because you don't want
some random passerby looking in on you
or
sneaking in to murder you insane on
theme this episode
so why would you let people look in on
you when you go online
which you do all the time if you don't
use a vpn using the internet without
expressvpn is like going to the bathroom
without closing the door and letting
someone come in and
cut your throat and we're not being
overdramatic here your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit
and if you are a murderer you don't want
an isp knowing that
whether you're a murderer or a murderer
you need some privacy
and what's worse worse than getting
murdered worse than dying
your internet service provider can sell
your information to ad companies and
tech giants who will use your data to
target you
and murder you express cpa puts a stop
to this zach it creates secure encrypted
tunnels between your device and the
internet
so that your online activity cannot be
seen by anyone
i use expressvpn on all my devices
because i'm the zodiac
it works on everything phones laptops
even routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi
can still be protected even if they
don't have expressvpn and the best part
is
using an expressvpn is as easy as
closing the bathroom door you just
fire up the app click one button and
you're protected expressvpn is the
world's number one rated vpn by cnet
wired the verge and countless others so
if you are like me and you believe your
online activity is your business and who
you murder or who you get murdered
by is your own business that no one
else's secure yourself by visiting
xrspn.com
bigq today use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
big q and you can get an extra three
months for free
it's free real estate that's xrsapn.comq
yes thank you to expressvpn also
thank you to football being back that's
right
shout out bill's mafia yeah somebody
sent me this in the mail
i still appreciate it football's back in
draftkings the leader in one day fantasy
sports
has millions of reasons why you should
be excited to kick off the football
season draftkings is giving new users
a free shot at a one million dollar top
prize
with a total of three million dollars up
for grabs for this thursday's football
contest
i gotta do it man
getting in on thursday nights single
game showdown is easy
all you have to do is download
draftkings using promo code
big question draft six players from the
season opener
stay under the salary cap and see how
your team stacks up against the
competition
head to the app now and start making it
rain and that's not precipitation rain
that's rei gm like you're a king
you're a draftking we're not worthy
we're not worthy plus new users who sign
up today on draftkings
using code big question will receive a
free shot at the one million dollar top
prize
with your first deposit nothing adds to
the sweat
of watching the game like having a shot
at a million dollar payday so
download the draftkings app now and use
code big question for a limited time new
users can get a free shot at the one
million dollar top prize and three
million dollars in total prizes
don't miss this extra special week one
bonus enter code big question to get a
free shot at the one million dollar top
prize with your first deposit that's
code
big question only at draftkings make it
rain
reign like that kind of rain minimum
five dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com for details all right
zach there's one
bite-sized question that i need an
answer from you and it's really the
biggest question i think a lot of us
have on our minds it's not just big it's
you but it's kind of hard to build an
episode around it so we put in the bite
size section tons of people everywhere
are asking are they going to release
black widow in future marvel films on
disney plus
on streaming online services like the
way disney did
with mulan so i kind of broke down the
numbers because i think they're pretty
interesting now
that we know what some of the pricing
and some of the early box office returns
are looking like for some of these
bigger movies
we know the price and the distribution
method for mulan and this is kind of
one of the first big big movies no
offense new mutants
no offense weird russell crowe road rage
movie
but like mulan's the first really big
delayed movie
that's going to come out and disney has
announced how they're going to release
it
it's going to be 30 on disney plus you
have to already be a subscriber of
disney plus
and then pay 30 on top of that you get
it on video on demand
basically that way and you can watch it
while it's out and then further down the
road in december they're going to
release it
just broadly on disney plus you don't
have to pay extra you just have to be a
subscriber
and they're doing this right in every
country that has disney plus
and in any country that doesn't have
disney plus they're releasing it in
theaters
most importantly in china china there's
no disney plus in china
and that's going to be a really big
market for mulan obviously it's a story
set
in china and that's just a really large
theater market
it's the second biggest after the us uh
and for some movies it's even bigger so
that's what we know about mulan and so
what we know about vod success
since quarantine started is largely
based on
the avengers end game of vod and i'm
talking about
trolls world tour okay uh
it legitimately broke records when it
came out it was the most successful
vod release ever it made about a hundred
million dollars
off of like five about five million
people paid 20 bucks to rent
trolls world tour largely those were
people who had children that were
driving them insane if they didn't uh
run
trolls world tour so that's kind of our
benchmark right so here's my back of the
envelope math and i'm calling this
trolls math
okay because uh for my lord and savior
uh justin timberlake as a troll dog
and i love you zach huddleston so again
if the trolls franchise
is at least probably less popular by
half
than the mcu it makes about half what an
average mcu made
okay trolls could make 100 million
dollars pretty easily on vod
if we double up that for an average mcu
movie like black widow
at a higher price right because trolls
made 100 million
but at 20 so if we both double the
number of people willing to rent it and
we increase the price from twenty
dollars to thirty dollars
we can get to three hundred million
dollars for black widow
probably pretty reasonably and again
disney gets to keep
all of that money instead of splitting
it with a vod or a theater
and three hundred million dollars
domestically puts it on pace with doctor
strange
ant-man and the wasp kind of your
mid-tier recent mcu movies
as far as domestic gross now let's say
black widow can also get them one
million extra disney plus subscribers
she's like are there a million people
that aren't currently on disney plus
that would sign up
just to watch black widow and then maybe
stick around for six months or a year
yeah maybe around the world yeah
worldwide so that gets them
disney another 100 million dollars again
they don't have to split with anybody
so now we're up to 400 million dollars
for black widow okay still pretty far
from our one billion dollar
magic number for marvel movies right but
then let's say they're still doing
international box office
it's kind of a hybrid thing it's a
little bit disney plus a little bit of
international box office in different
markets people are still going to want
to see this movie in theaters maybe even
if they have the option of watching it
on disney plus so let's say they can
even get
half of what a normal mcu movie gets at
the international box office
so like usually again your thor
ragnaroks your spider-man
homecomings can get 400 to 500 million
dollars
total from the rest of the world outside
of the united states so let's say you
could get half of that
sure some countries are going to have
some shutdowns there'll be social
distancing in force in some theaters so
maybe the
the numbers are a little bit lower
theaters might have to drop their prices
to incentivize people to come back
but if they can get half of what an
average marvel movie gets that's 200
million dollars
disney only gets to take home half of
that so that's another 100 million
so then that kind of gets them to about
500 million dollars
which is more than kind of your ironman
twos or your early kind of
phase one phase two marvel movies
is it is it a huge success no
not compared to captain marvel or black
panther
but it also keeps disney from just
losing
a ton of money so like you could see
some kind of mixed strategy like this
happening for black widow i think it
could happen depending on their internal
calculations
interesting thank you for breaking down
all those numbers for us zach we have
time for one more
uh boxes wraps question and we're
staying on the theme of murder here
the question is what is the closest
you've ever gotten to being
murdered both you and i
kind of lived worked spent a lot of time
in hollywood
not the industry necessarily but the
neighborhood
and uh for uh people outside of la or
having visited la or something like that
the neighborhood of hollywood
is not where they make movies it's just
kind of a mixed like working class
kind of neighborhood has some sketchy
nightlife um i lived there for a lot of
my first 10 years in los angeles walked
home alone late at night
you know hung out in uh some seedier
bars so i was probably getting
relatively close to murder
on a monthly or weekly basis but the
closest i ever got so i lived in a house
in hollywood kind of in the middle of
like working class hollywood
with two other people one of my
roommates was gone one night and it was
myself
and this woman who's my third roommate i
didn't know that well she'd just been
there temporarily
and we were everybody was about to move
out of the house uh we'd kind of closed
our lease
it was our last month there we everybody
had a new place to move to
but you know it was one of the last
weeks and so there were for rent signs
on the outside of the house
and so i go to bed not thinking anything
of it i wake up the next morning
my bedroom door is open
i always closed it of course and then it
kind of come out
in the room eight she's there and she's
like hey did you
um forget your keys last night and i was
like
no no i was i was just normal i was
watching tv in my room or something like
that
she's like oh cause i thought i heard
somebody breaking in last night
and so we kind of look around and
in the kind of the living room of this
home the window screen had been popped
off
of the window a bit there's like a hole
torn in it like somebody like
yanked it off uh but the window was
locked and then we kind of walked around
and looked and like
most of the window screens had been torn
off the windows and eventually we
looked and in the bathroom there was one
of those like weird windows that's like
i don't know it's only like this tall
kind of a long one that's kind of like
high up above the shower
i leave those open all the time you
gotta get you know you take those big
nasty shits
something's gone or a big nasty shower
whatever you're doing in the
big nasty toothbrush whatever so um that
that window had been closed but it had
been
unlocked the screen was popped off and
in the back in the bathtub
directly underneath that window were
muddy footprints
oh and by the way we also discovered
that the front door was unlocked
which again i had locked it before i
went to bed we didn't leave our front
door unlocked
and so i pieced together this is exactly
what happened okay
somebody saw the for rent sign i don't
know if it was uh
a drug addict a homeless person a
vagrant just a near duel whatever
and assumed that the home was vacant
and maybe they're looking for a warm
place to sleep at night this had to have
been very
late i you know it was after i went to
bed they try to get in try to get in
finally they find a window
they crawl in through the bathtub and
luckily
i think they came to my bedroom first
they opened up a door
saw a dude sleeping in a bed and we're
like oh crap this place is not vacant
and so then they just walked out the
front door they didn't steal anything
they didn't hurt anybody
but like they definitely broke in and
then looked around and then left
i was just like maybe the real answer to
this question is i don't know how close
to
murder i was but i really felt scared
for my female roommate i was like oh
thank god that person walked into my
bedroom first
assuming they were a male and could have
been up to no good
right like i'm i'm glad they might have
saw my giant lucky body
uh on a bed and and left not wanting any
of it so
i don't know that that's my like unaware
closest to
to murder moment i think and zach we
know when you sleep you're you're doing
arm curls
actually so that's right i'm also i
sleep covered in knives
you know i just have blades laying all
over me so it gives off a very uh
scary energy and unfortunately your
other roommate brandon barrack was
murdered but you know
rest in peace what's the closest you've
ever been to getting murdered eric
well when i was researching zodiac uh a
lot of the
the early attacks were couples who were
on dates who were just like on these
remote dates they were picnicking
whatever it was
and i remembered how my girlfriend and i
on one of our first dates
we went and got dinner um in downtown
santa monica
and then after the date um on santa
monica beach they have these
little sidewalks that lead out to these
benches that are like on these concrete
platforms that just face a beach
so you know every 100 yards or so on the
beach there's one of these and it's just
like a place you can walk to
without having to get your feet all
sandy and just sit on the bench and get
to watch the waves
and she knew about the spot i was like
ooh okay uh we go there and you know
the we were sitting out there we were
just kind of like stargazing
and it was nice and romantic and out in
santa monica there's people like walking
around there's people walking down the
beach couples walking down the beach but
it kind of feels like a lover's lane
kind of thing
we're looking at a boat lights on the
water we're trying to guess how far away
the boat was
because there's usually boats that are
out there and you know
not to get too personal but we we like
turned in and we had a moment
he blew into my mouth and uh it lasted a
couple minutes but
you know your your eyes are closed
hopefully your eyes are closed when
you're kissing someone
uh oh but it's very nice
and then you know a couple minutes later
several minutes later
uh we kind of pull apart and we're just
enjoying the moment
and we look right out uh and you know
behind us are like street lights there's
like
a parking lot so our eyes had adjusted
from that light because we were turned
into each other so now our eyes are
adjusting to the darkness
and we see a new light out on the water
it's this orange light that is uh
glowing bright
and then going dark and then glowing
bright and going dark
and then we realize as our eyes are
adjusting at the same time we realize
wait a minute that's not a boat that's a
guy
smoking a cigarette there was a dude
who was halfway between us on the beach
between us in the water smoking a
cigarette
staring at us just waiting for
whatever i don't know if he was enjoying
the show
but he was like 20 yards away from us at
the same time we both kind of whispered
to each other
there's a man staring at us let's leave
and we both stood up and quickly walked
back to our car
who knows if we would have been murdered
but zack they never caught
zodiac so it could have been him
wow it's the most frightened i've been
now i will say there are other moments
i've been closer probably to getting
murdered but it's a time when philip and
i and some other friends were out on a
trip and i
want to save that story because it's
really philip
it's it's more his story than my story i
want him to tell it when he inevitably
comes back
and makes his grand return to do
rockstars being on camera he didn't
leave he still works for do rockstars
he's just working on personal projects
but when he comes back we will make him
tell the story of how we were really
actually almost murdered hey i want to
apologize to you eric
back when i used to smoke i did a lot of
really creepy things uh
so i i apologize for staring at you and
not saying hello
knew it was you and and then yes i too
can't wait
for philip and you to tell that story
because i feel like any time philip is
involved with a story
it's about 40 darker than i anticipate
it being so
that guy has he's been chased by demons
like he
he has seen some terrifying [ __ ] so if
you really want to get scared
let phillip talk to you about his life a
little bit okay yeah and that is our
show
it was so great to talk murder with you
zack it was my favorite multiverse with
eric and zach
and uh what a time we had reminder that
you can join our official discord server
by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars and there you can
ask us
the big questions that we're most likely
to see it there with with our patrons on
discord you also get an audio version of
the show by subscribing to new rockstars
big question wherever you get your
podcasts
and you can send us your big questions
on twitter as well by using the hashtag
bigquestion
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
zach at z
huddleston on social media and follow
new rockstars on social subscribe here
on youtube to get too much information
on all the stuff you care about thanks
for watching
thanks zach see you next time
[Music]
you